hello everyone and welcome back to the
show that today aims to fly directly in
the face of the iconic foursome known as
the ghostbusters because we have two
film franchises who provide such an
impressive gaggle of ghostly goings-on
that you will be afraid of ghosts as
there's many strange things in the
neighborhood and who you gonna call
the warrens are a good place to start
but just in case they're skeptical bring
your camcorder it's the conjuring
universe taking on the paranormal
activity franchise right now on versus
in one corner you have the most ordinary
san diego family in history or so it
would seem you see their pension for
home video production is surpassed only
by their terror at what is going on
inside the house is it a ghost a demon a
family of overwhelmingly mischievous
raccoons we'll have plenty of tape to
review but in the other corner it's a
family famous for not being ordinary in
fact the warrens are known to be
somewhat in tune with the strange and
unusual and maybe undead is it a ghost
is it a demon they're just a series of
door hinges that need wd-40 and a
strange-looking doll from yesteryear
it's going to be a pretty even matchup
here that you'll want to revisit again
and again if for no other reason because
going down the rabbit hole with these
two properties i have a feeling you're
gonna be awake most of the night here's
how we'll determine a winner round one
box office round two tomato meter slash
audience score round three familia round
four ah
and then we'll do a wild card round that
paranormal activity hopes will involve
who can stand perfectly still over a bed
the longest i now film my nighttime
sleep habits and last night i got a new
record i stood at the side of my bed for
over an hour never moved never blinked
the dog freaked out i don't remember any
of it pretty impressive it's the
ultimate paranormal investigation team
taking on the family that gets their
house haunted the most and the warrens
of the rays are just the starting
lineups in this ball game wait until
toby and valik check into the contest
team spirit let's get it on round one
box office
both paranormal activity and the
conjuring did buffo box office when
their respective franchises were
launched but we're pitting the entire
properties against each other because
their sequels and prequels have
continued to haul in major moola at the
multiplex and set movie going records
paranormal activity hit first in 2007
and the tiny independent film that could
from director orrin pelley would go on
to rake in almost 200 million dollars in
theaters across the globe all on a
shoestring budget of 15 000
that's seriously enough to buy just
shoestrings there's air jordans out
there worth 30 times that much
now the franchise has six total films
none of which have dipped below the 77
million dollar mark and the first four
movies never fell below 140 million
dollars in worldwide cash the all-time
breadwinner for family to paranormal is
part three which scared up 207 million
dollars yep we knew i'd use a cheesy
term like scared up eventually come on
have you not seen the show before i'm
actually working on a theory that
dollars and cents do move more if
they're frightened we're still in beta
testing all told the paranormal activity
team has done 890 million dollars across
earth making for a per film average of
148 million dollars and that's all with
a few security cameras and kitchen
appliances 2013 is when the conjuring
would hit theaters and it was feeling
confident right from the get-go opening
that summer in the midst of blockbuster
season james wan's inaugural entry in
the universe de warren earned 317
million dollars on a budget of just 20
million bucks since then this franchise
has been rewriting hollywood history
books only one film of the eight total
movies the curse of while yorona did
under 200 million dollars worldwide and
four films in the set have grossed over
300 million bucks the highest earner of
any movie we'll talk about today is the
none ah the nun it pulled in a church
collection plate record of 363 million
dollars in donations to the movie after
doing over two billion dollars worth of
combined business for a per movie
average of 263 million dollars you may
be asking yourself mark the country's
crushing it what chance does pa have in
this round
it's actually got a good one that's the
good news for paranormal activity fans
the bad news is that it will require me
to do math oh the one thing scarier than
ghosts under my bed let's open our ap
calculus books to the budget page one
more time the conjuring films cost way
less than your run-of-the-mill
blockbusters as films like captain
batman and jurassic skywalker regularly
cost upwards of 200 million dollars to
pull off the conjuring horror series by
contrast costs an average of around 25
million dollars per flick it's mere
pennies to a gigantic studio but
paranormal activity has never had a film
cost more than 10 million dollars to
make and the budgetary average across
its movies is around 5 million so that's
a quarter of the cost of one of them
high fluent annabelle the nun joints and
while the conjuring more than doubles up
paranormal activity in terms of total
gross and outweighs it by more than 100
million dollars per outing the return on
investment of each paranormal activity
film far exceeds anything else that
hollywood has ever seen the blair witch
project walked so paranormal folk could
run and six movies later they're still
sprinting their way to the bank in an
upset special paranormal activities
david defeats the conjuring's goliath
and gets on the board first one to
nothing oh no that was a bible reference
oh and the nun she's gonna kill me
excuse me round two tomato meter slash
audience score so we've upset the
conjuring and toby the demon is probably
celebrating with a glass of champagne
he's sipping on camera freaking out the
house guest but now we arrive at the
round that is more nuanced than some
accounting bottom line what did all
those folks that paid good hard cash to
see your scary pictures think when they
finally stopped shrieking let's take a
walk on the audience score side it's
pretty scary for the conjuring but in
this matchup the more frights the better
five out of the eight total flicks in
the series are fresh according to the
audience and it's the three conjuring
movies leading the way they all boast an
80 percent or above the og's at 83
percent part two is at 81 and the most
recent entry the devil made me do it is
the all-time high for any film competing
today at 84 percent only annabelle the
nun and the curse of why your own a dip
below fresh with each landing somewhere
in the rotten territory of the 30th
percentile however i will point out that
annabelle rebounded well as both the
prequel and the sequel are fresh
creation is at 67
and annabelle comes home is at 70
percent yeah who turns it to do the
dishes now chucky the conjuring film
series averages a super impressive 61.1
percent fresh on the audience score and
if you think those point one percents
aren't important paranormal activity
would take all the fractions it could
muster none i repeat
none not as in the none as in n-o-n-e
no movies in the paranormal activity
franchise are fresh according to the
audience not a one
what do you mean the original made a
good effort earning 57 percent and part
three the preferred movie of fan
salespeople is also competitive at 51
percent but from there it's all downhill
and the most recent entry the ghost
dimension set the low bar at 27
all six films combined for an audience
score average that's yes rotten 41.8
percent the tomato meter does brighten
up team paranormal spirits however as
two of the movies are fresh on that
scale do you want to guess which ones
it's the same two parts one and three
weigh in at a robust 83 percent and 66
respectively but anchoring the set to
the basement is part 4 23
and the ghost dimension at 14
14
jeez what's in that dimension movie 43
uh hard to tell you know it's
it's an old piano
and a whole bunch of garbage thus the
tomato meter average for paranormal
activity films is still rotting at 47.1
percent all right conjuring squad can
y'all shore up this round by being
critical darlings as well as audience
favorites damn right they ken four of
the eight films are fresh led by the
first two conjuring movies and the most
recent two annabelle flicks okay now
chucky you're taking out the trash and
watching the kids mom is going out
tonight creation's at 71 percent and
annie comes home 65
meanwhile the conjuring is the overall
high bar at 86 percent and part two is
it 80
and the devil made me do it is fresh
adjacent at 56
hey with those grades we might get a
scholarship but the other three films
are all in the 20s so we might not go to
grad school who cares we're making it in
hollywood baby we're scaring up an
average of 54.8 percent for all the
conjuring movies and anyone who says i
might have weighed round one towards
paranormal activity is going to be happy
now the conjuring gets a decisive win
here ties the match at one to one and
has the momentum as we dive into round
three
you think you can try not to be
completely rude to him round three
familia that's the italian word for
family or at least that's what i was
told from the olive garden menu that
word also sounds like farmiga the last
name of vera who plays the iconic
lorraine warren in the conjuring films
this round will be all about those
closest to us as in the primary families
that must duel these unsightly tears
bonus points will be awarded for any
tertiary characters who made a lasting
contribution but let's start with the
figureheads themselves lorraine the
clairvoyant and ed the other guy in the
relationship the warrens were a real
couple that famously took on many a
paranormal investigation and while their
legacy is continually sealed by
blockbuster horror flicks based on their
adventures the reality of what they were
actually about seems muddled some feel
they were honest the goodness heroes who
sought out the supernatural tears that
most of us would run away from helping
folks overcome their literal demons in
the process others claim it was all a
show that they were little more than
charlatans taking advantage of
unsuspecting townies with myths about
ghosts and ghouls and goblins but as far
as the conjuring universe itself goes
there are fearless protagonists who
always have some connection to the
events of a film in the series in what
could be a deciding round in this match
it's interesting that these two primary
families the warrens and the paranormal
activities the rays are polar opposites
in the purpose they serve whereas the
warrens are actively seeking out the
unusual to counter any demonic presences
that may exist the reys they're just a
normal couple who had these unusual
events happen to them they probably
could have used the warren's help but
that's also what makes them such
compelling characters they're just like
us regardless of that one dream your
auntie had the vast majority of us are
not in touch with the other side or the
great beyond or whatever spirits like
bashiba and toby hail from that place we
can much more easily identify with katie
and micah than ed and lorraine simply
because we don't claim ghost hunting is
an expertise even though i did put it on
my resume yeah you got to have some
talent however that's what makes the
warrens the heroes of their stories like
indiana jones or where croft we're just
along for the ride as we follow this
intrepid duo down the darkest of pass
similarly we're just as scared as katie
and micah when we see the found footage
of unexplainable phenomena in fact we
may be one step ahead of the rays
because we're home babysitting whatever
that invisible force is that jess sets
something on fire while they're out on
the town it's such a unique dichotomy of
character background that we're gonna
have to take a look at who else shows up
in these films taking a cue from dr
friedrichs in the original it seems like
every paranormal activity flick has some
sort of expert that we need to learn
from halfway into the movie it's their
job to show us what we're dealing with
and how to hopefully stop it conversely
the warrens meet folks like the rays all
the time it's the parent family in part
one the hodgson's in part two and so on
and so forth demi and beshear and linda
carnellini have also lent their talents
to the nun and the curse of why your
honor respectively and their tales are
always compelling where i side with the
conjuring in this phase is that the
stories sprawl across countries
generations and demon riding vessels one
movie could have a painting that seems
to move the next a freaky looking doll
that no one wants to see under a
christmas tree i guess we can give some
points for the villainous entities
themselves valik bathsheba annabelle and
other dark forces have terrorized scared
townsfolk in the conjuring series for
centuries but i really find myself most
enamored with toby whose singular
devotion to wrecking one namesake in
particular is almost admirable and the
glee with which he does it is not to be
overlooked for every fun clap game
moment in the conjuring there's tons of
silly tricks toby plays on his um
contestants it's almost as if toby is
starring in impractical jokers and has
his buddies in his ear telling him how
to punk the rays and their pals next but
when it all comes down to it this is
about the warrens and their real history
with battling evil from another
dimension do i buy that they actually
took on all these cases and the events
played out exactly like they did in the
film
no not necessarily but there was
something going on with all these
families and no skeptic can pin all of
that on a couple of religion babbling
swindlers the genius of the paranormal
activity films is that it feels like
it's actually happening but with the
conjuring some version of these events
did in fact occur maybe not to the level
depicted on screen but i can't rule
against ed and lorraine because if i do
they probably have value's number on
speed dial and then i have to deal with
a spooky nun in my bathroom mirror the
familiar round goes in favor of the
conjuring and that franchise takes a 2-1
lead you did good
no you did
round four
yes that is the noise i make when i'm
scared by a horror movie it's a higher
pitched version of how my dog's tummy
sounds when she's hungry always feed
your guard dog who according to her mom
has barked at an evil spirit in an old
house before that was before i met them
but yeah
don't go in that house and when it comes
to movie frights these two properties
have given as many chills as anything
else in the 2000s but which film set
features more creeps crawls and curses
this round will be won by the franchise
that is quite simply the scariest once
again the conjuring will gain some
points for being based on true events
but that field position is given right
back because i know it couldn't have
possibly gotten his cray-cray as it
looked on screen the end of the
conjuring is an awesome exercise and
completely wrecking a kitchen but for me
it's the quieter scares that get under
our skin like that clap game that sold
the movie from the teaser trailer alone
james one has become the modern master
of the jump scare employing the
technique not as some cheap thrill but
as a true heart-poundingly necessary
addition to the story just check out the
face lorraine sees in the mirror in that
inaugural conjuring outing that's the
kind of fright that follows you home
from the theater whenever i think of
paranormal activity i think of how lucky
these kids are to be around other people
and in a house built on love i'm not
much of a relationship guy because it
cuts into my watching football by myself
schedule but my lifestyle choice really
bites me in the rear when i watch one of
those movies i'm all alone and no one is
going to believe me if this happens at
my place
well besides the dog many times in these
flicks it takes the footage reviewed to
convince the cynics so take an amazingly
well done kitchen sequence from
paranormal activity 2. there's christy
sitting in a modern high-top barstool
reading a magazine when everything goes
bananas at the same exact time cabinets
explode out and nothing on earth can
explain what the hell happened dogs and
cats living together it's a fun surprise
because a it's a good jump scare and b
wow does toby go above and beyond the
call of duty toby you could have just
flown a chair over but this guy really
goes the extra mile the nun takes us
back to the 1950s to a mysterious
convent and those two words rarely team
up to bring me a good night of sleep the
lack of modern appliances adds to an
atmosphere of eerie lighting long
hallways and that whispering wind and
then we see the nun not a nun mind you
the nun as in the demonic presence it
feels right at home wearing a habit and
could care less about holy water or
crosses one of the great scares here is
when we the audience can see a faceless
nun trailing a very nervous very
intrepid sister irene and we think
that's the scariest thing going on until
get this another nun double teams her
pops out of nowhere like is wrestlemania
25 and a new competitor has entered the
ring you could even garner lots of
scares and dark circles under your eyes
at work the next day from the lesser
scene films in these franchises like in
the ghost dimension when a dark figure
in lyla's room can only be seen on
videotape we'd seen similar images in
horror movies before but the setup feels
fresh in the moment and really adds pop
to the most recent pa entry then you
have lyrona you know you think drowning
your kids would be enough but nope let's
keep messing with any little tyke we can
get our hands on the bathtub sequence
where we see a much older grayer deader
set of hands shampooing a child is
terrifying sure the kid may be getting
zestfully clean but at what cost
additional points here because the
actress who plays la yorona is my pal
marisol ramirez she's a sweetheart
as far as i know inventive scares up the
ante even more for me in this round
check out annabelle doing what teddy
ruxpin never could she bends poor
anthony with paulia's fingers back
before contorting his very soul in a way
that science tells us should be
impossible it's so deliciously
disgustingly evil and it proves that no
doll should ever find a home in any
residence other than the warren's room
of creepy crap it's that antiquities
room that not even the pawn stars would
go near the sextet of blocks are on that
door for a reason there ain't nothing
but bad mojo in there mojo that could
spur the conjuring onto a win in this
round but ingenuity was at an all-time
high in paranormal activity three and
the best example of this
a camcorder mounted to an oscillating
fan by the third movie we're tired of
the static shots showing us part of the
scary action so we figured out a new
improved home security setup where a fan
moving back and forth can show us a
clear picture of the hell that toby has
wrought but be careful what you wish for
poor lisa the babysitter never should
have told that scary story it's a great
way to refresh found footage in an era
where that style was starting to get
stale and it's a tiebreaker here in a
tooth and nail round about what scares
me the most the warrens may have
experienced all of these horrific events
exactly the way they appear in the
movies fair enough i don't want to have
a sleepover but paranormal activity is
so cagey smart because it feels real
it's ingenious without ever going over
the top surprising but never ridiculous
and that is more than enough to frighten
anyone who like me lives by themselves
in a palatial estate i got a bedroom i
got two bathrooms and laundry in unit so
yeah i can take care of those bloody
sheets without looking like a serial
killer at the laundromat pa wins the
round ah and we're tied at two to two
you leave my family alone you hear me i
don't know what you are but you leave my
wife alone god damn it and now it's time
for the wild card round haunted history
yes i take these films just as seriously
as my job in judging them but at the end
of the day i know the paranormal
activity movies are fictional and the
conjuring features very dramatized
versions of possibly true events but all
that debate as to what's real and what's
hollywood magic gets tossed by the
wayside in this round because each film
franchise features another backstory how
they got to screen and in both instances
some actual ghostly activity may have
occurred
i just felt something on the back of my
did anybody
is the air conditioning okay now i'm
nervous i'm actually scared right now
horror film mythology includes strange
things happening on the set of big time
scary blockbusters like the exorcist and
poltergeist but the conjuring might just
take the spooky occurrence cake to be
clear the first film was shot in a
replica house built for the movie not in
any actual haunted location but
apparently the spirits didn't get that
memo both beer farmiga and patrick
wilson reported supernatural experiences
while filming for amigas showed up in
the physical world in the form of
mysterious claw marks they first
appeared electronically because i guess
that's much more modern and convenient
on her laptop and iphone but then she
saw a similar looking unexplained scar
on her thigh and it was yes claw marks
or at least that's what we think and
that's just the opening act the haze
brothers who co-wrote the first film
both had some bizarre creepiness to deal
with in real life carrie hayes wife
wasn't on set but rather back at his
home while he was out of town working on
the film but she repeatedly found
inexplicable water spots on the floor
around their abode at first they thought
it might just be their elderly dog
relieving itself but the liquid scent
didn't match that theory and when hayes
told the real life lorraine warren about
this she postulated that it was a water
spirit and they tend to manifest when
one mate is out of the house for maximum
scare effect and both the brothers were
privy to actual undoctored footage of
warren cases where they saw things like
for instance a third grader speaking
perfect latin backwards and crying blood
now when i think of me in third grade i
could barely speak english forward i
cried a lot but it was never blood
paranormal activity may be rooted in
fiction but that didn't stop something
from messing with none other than steven
spielberg according to legend
spielberg's company dreamworks was
considering coming on board the project
so he took a dvd of orin pelley's film
to his pacific palisades home he watched
it was enthralled and became
enthusiastic about the possibilities but
soon after spielberg viewed it his house
got a bad case of the
somethings his bedroom somehow locked
its own door from the inside forcing
steven to call a locksmith he was
excited about the film but not the dvd
he immediately took it right back to the
studio offices in a garbage bag other
tales from the set of pa films include
some odd occurrences but nothing can
match the freaky set of the conjuring 2.
filmed primarily at warner brothers
studio 4 a known location where
hauntings had been said to take place
the ghost took full advantage of this
particular shoot after filming it
wrapped for the day crew members
reported hearing the sounds of hammering
and nails underneath the sound stage but
no one was there and their cell phone
footage and assistant took and showed to
director james wan of curtin's moving
all by themselves with no wind and
nothing was behind them either
seriously no one else feels that ac
right now
but the deciding blow that the conjuring
will land to win this round is the
artifact room again this was a
reimagining of the real warrens home but
it turned out to be frighteningly
accurate although they were ostensibly
just props there was a mysterious pig
head that would magically switch where
it was located every time someone
entered the room spirits may be a little
shy but they know when a movie is being
made about them and they demand full
credit whether these tales are 100
accurate we'll probably never know but
much like the conjuring franchise itself
wow are they entertaining paranormal
activity will never not scare the crap
out of me but team warren wins this
round and thus
the match
[Music]
i'm really not looking forward to coming
home tonight after ruling against toby i
bet molly the wonder dog is already
barking at absolutely nothing in the
corner of my bedroom but if tobe or any
other demonic ghoul is watching this
poor is on set right now remember this
is just my opinion now the world gets
its set
so you know
go haunt them now let your voice be
heard right now by hitting us up on
social media i'm at mark ellis live and
make sure you tag at rotten tomatoes as
well thanks for tuning in today and
until next time never play with creepy
1950s dolls or cross a graveyard into a
convent or befriend anyone in san diego
named katie or micah look i know it's a
lot of rules i'm trying to keep you safe
here i'm mark ellis and you keep those
cameras off of an oscillating fan
you